today on the Matt Walsh show the left
now wants to defund the police today
well we'll try to understand what that
actually means and and and who could be
crazy enough to support it that's the
other question we'll try to try to get
get into all that today also five
headlines including MIT Romney going
full BLM and in our daily cancellation
I'm gonna cancel all the people who are
trying to cancel JK Rowling because she
said that men can't have periods that is
a obviously very controversial statement
these days and so she's being cancelled
for that for that but I'm gonna reverse
cancel then it's very confusing so it's
it's a it's a it's a difficult maneuver
to pull off but I'm gonna try to do that
at the end of the show today okay so we
begin with this defunding the police the
latest brilliant idea to be proposed by
our friends on the left they want to
defund the police and unless you think
that that this is nothing but a
delusional pipe dream well it is
delusional of course but it isn't just a
dream this is something that they're
actually setting out to do Minneapolis
is moving in this direction right now as
we speak a veto-proof majority of
Minneapolis City Council members have
already announced their intention to
disband and defund the police department
in the city the mayor of Minneapolis
Jacob Frye you know he hasn't been
paying very much attention to everything
that's been going on he'd already let
violent mobs rampage through the city
for two weeks he let them burn down a
precinct he let them do whatever they
want to and here's what he's been up to
while all this is going on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is it any wonder that a man wearing
pants like that would be unfit to govern
but the dancing mayor he got a dose of
reality this weekend finally when he
went to a black lives matter
demonstration and after they did the
Macarena and the cha-cha slide and the
YMCA after all that being included he
was asked about this idea of getting rid
of the police and here's how that went
for him jacob frye we know but yes or no
question for you yes or no will you to
make funding Minneapolis
[Music]
all right why y'all because it's bloody
action here just cuz if y'all don't know
he's up for re-election next and if he
says no guess what they'll we don't do
next year
now this is what you just saw there I
keep in mind as I said this guy let the
BLM radicals do whatever they want burn
down a police precinct burn down half
the city loot pillage assault attack
police officers a know everything he
gave him free rein ok he watched the
purge basically he watched the purge and
took it as a how-to video for mayors and
after all of that he still got cussed
out and booed off the stage because he
had the audacity to suggest that maybe
we shouldn't officially and totally get
rid of the law enforcement permanently
you know he wouldn't go that far
he said yeah I mean you could burn stuff
down bro I'll give you like two weeks to
burn down whatever you want do whatever
you want
assault kill people do what you want you
want to burn down here you want to burn
down a police but it's go ahead go ahead
just go ahead yeah sure still not enough
not enough for them and this is what
happens with the left
they will never be happy they will never
be satisfied they will never be satiated
nothing you do will ever be enough
especially if you're a white man if
you're a white man forget it
you're the villain and there's nothing
you can do and that's that's the lesson
that jacob frye is learning right now
that you can't and here's the other
thing baikal toweling and submitting and
apologizing and groveling you're not
gonna let you you're not gonna make them
be nice to you except maybe temporarily
okay that's what Jacob Frye was but he
thought at least they'd be nice to him
well they're not being nice to him but
especially you're not gonna make anyone
respect you that way maybe they'll be
nice to you temporarily in a certain
context until you say you don't want to
define the police and then they and then
they cuss you out and kid the way
they're talking to the mayor that way
can we just all of these there's so much
that we've been seeing over the last two
weeks and and really you know
over the last few years that is it's all
become so normal to us but even just
that video right they take everything
else aside just that video of the mayor
of a city being treated that way like
ten years ago that would been
unthinkable and now it's just yeah it's
a video you see and you move on from it
but what you see there's a total lack of
respect for this guy
we have no respect for him whatsoever
and can you blame them
I'm not sitting here saying they should
respect him why would you respect a
mayor who just let you burn down the
city and I as I said I don't feel sorry
for him
even if it did look like he was gonna
cry there a little bit I do feel sorry
for the law-abiding citizens of
Minneapolis all 14 of them who now are
about to have their city taken over
permanently by the mob and there's
nothing they can do about it now this
idea of defunding the police has gained
steam rapidly not just in Minneapolis it
has like so many crazy leftist ideas
gone from fringe to mainstream at
Lightspeed
it goes from you gotta get a few radical
people talking about it too it's it's
everywhere and this is where you know
the mainstream media is very helpful in
this regard for the left so we call it
the mainstream media they could take
these fringe radical leftist ideas and
inject them right into the bloodstream
of the mainstream and and this is what
they've been doing with this now if
you're wondering what this actually
means what it would look like what the
implications are of an idea like this
well the thing is the people proposing
it aren't really answering those
questions all we get our emotional
appeals shouting screaming that's all
they have the best I could do and I've
been looking around just to see like
what okay you're saying to fund the
police I already know it's a crazy idea
but tell me about it what do you even
really mean by that and it's very hard
to get answers to that question but I
did find a few answers from a few
different sources and I want to get into
those and we'll talk about that in just
a
but first I want to tell you about our
friends at Euro you know I've had the
experience of especially where I live
kind of out out in the middle of nowhere
of having horrible Wi-Fi service and for
the job that I do that that could be
very d causes a lot of problems but even
without this job you know could
considering how connected we are
everything is online these days you got
to have good Wi-Fi Eero is the Wi-Fi
your home deserves blanketing your whole
home with fast reliable Wi-Fi and it's
not just inside but outside too hero
extends you're covered so you can enjoy
the nicer weather and get work done by
your deck you know we have a like to
spend a lot of time out on our back
porch before Eero I haven't been able to
get the internet out there but now I can
gyro eliminates poor coverage dead spots
and buffering you'll have a consistently
strong single signal wherever you go
euro sets up in minutes plugs right into
your modem and your your router box and
you manage it from a from a very simple
app it's all very simple very quick
that's what it's all about with with
this sort of thing I think simple and
quick you can get yours fixed as soon as
tomorrow if you're having Wi-Fi issues
go to eurocom slash Walsh
enter code Walsh at checkout to get free
next day shipping with your order that's
e e ro dot-com slash Walsh code wall
should check out to get your arrow
delivered with free next day shipping
you must use this URL to receive this
offer so again that's eurocom slash
walsh EE ro comm / Walsh code Walsh
alright so what does this actually mean
defund the police I looked around it's
hard to get answers I did find this from
CNN Headline there's a growing call to
defund the police here's what it means
all right and then it goes into it says
there's a growing group of dissenters
who believe Americans can survive
without law enforcement as we know it
and Americans those dissenters believe
may even be better off without it the
solution to police brutality and racial
inequalities is police in policing a
simple supporter say just defund the
police it's as straightforward as it
sounds instead of funding a police
department a sizeable chunk of a city's
budget is invested in communities
especially marginalized ones or much of
the policing occurs
but and then it goes on does defunding
the police mean disbanding the police
that depends on who you ask said Philip
Mackerras a doctoral candidate and
sociology Yale University and lead
research and policy associate at the
community resource hub for safety and
accountability some supporters of
divestment want to reallocate some but
not all funds away from police
departments to Social Services some want
to strip all police funding and dissolve
departments the concept exists on a
spectrum the leftists love their
spectrums everything's on a spectrum
with them but both both interpretations
Center on reimagining what Public Safety
looks like this is interesting isn't it
usually we're told that the way to fix a
problem is to throw money at it want to
fix the schools dump money into it oh
the problem isn't fixed yet just dump
some more money into it Oh still not
fixed well I know we'll do more money
and on and on into infinity but with
police apparently the solution is to
take money away perhaps all money all
funding this is this is honestly the
only area where where the left would
ever suggest that taking money away is
how you solve the problem with
everything else especially where the
government is concerned it's all about
more money more money more money and so
maybe if they're capable of connecting
these dots which I don't think they are
but maybe it should start to think if
you really believe that these police
departments have too much money you
should take some of it away or all of it
well then you think about the school so
why do you think why do you think that
more money there is gonna fix the
problems one other point about what I
just read before we get to the main
point it says that black Americans don't
feel protected by the police I thought
it think I read that part it says it
also means dismantling the idea that
police are public stewards meant to
protect communities many black Americans
and other people of color don't feel
protected by police McAra said okay so
they don't feel protected alright and
and maybe that's how some of them feel
and
I'm sorry that they feel that way but
the reality the actual reality is that
black Americans like white Americans are
protected by the police
okay cops protect black people they do
they die protecting
black people in fact in the city
especially many cops are black
themselves so these are black police
officers protecting other black people
now not all of them do there are some
bad cops out there but the majority this
is what they do what the left wants to
do is get rid of law enforcement not
based on any reality or in response to
any reality but based on how people feel
in response to feelings it's it's you
know you often hear this claim that cops
are a leading cause of death for young
black men I'm sure you've seen that over
the last couple of weeks a leading cause
of death a leading cause of death which
makes you wonder is it a Liva
okay it's a leading cause is it like top
three is it number one is it top five
the answer is no okay it's way down
there on the list and it does make you
wonder what causes of death come before
police on that list if we're worried
about the leading causes of death what
are the causes of death that are much
more common than police and we know one
of them you know the cause of death for
young black men that far far far
outpaces police is other young black men
okay you look at the homicide rate the
hundreds of homicides that happen in
every single major city in America every
single year vast majority of them are
young black men being killed and in the
vast majority of cases they're being
killed by other young black men and not
ones that have a badge in a uniform so
you get rid of police what happens then
do those murders magically stop the
people just stop okay you get rid of
police and now no one's gonna be killed
by police anymore yeah because they're
not around to kill you fine but there
are a whole lot of people who are
getting killed by those who are not in
the police department
and what happens to them do all of the
murderers just say well police aren't
around anymore I guess we'll stop
killing no I don't think the murders
magically stopped and if they don't
magically stop who investigates those
crimes and seeks justice for them who
goes and pursues the criminals who puts
them in jail or do we not care about
justice for those victims now this is
the most obvious question raised by the
concept of defunding the police if we
don't have police what do we do when
someone is murdered or raped or robbed
or carjacked or experiences any of the
other eventualities common to people who
live in the city or just visit it from
time to time and here's a pretty
incredible thing or perhaps not so
incredible the people who've advanced
this proposal of defunding the police
they don't have an answer for this
question in most cases they just don't
answer it that's their answer they don't
have well they don't bother answering it
you know the question that you would
think that the first question you'd
think they'd come up with some kind of
answer for is this because it's the
first thing anyone's gonna say is it
well we should define the police first
response is going to be what do you mean
what about the murderers what are we
gonna do about them they have no answer
for that their plan is no plan this is
mob mentality personified a lot of anger
a lot of yelling many demands are made
no plan nothing coherent nothing
concrete and I've looked because I'd be
very interested if someone who could
come up with some kind of coherent plan
for what we do about robbers murderers
carjackers etc if we don't have police
and there's no answer now the president
of Minneapolis if you don't believe me
that there's no plan here the president
of the Minneapolis City Council who's
one of the people who's actually going
working towards enacting this utopia of
no police she was asked this question on
CNN and we're gonna get to her response
in a second
but before we do I want to tell you
about rad power
I've told you they're one of the
sponsors on this show and we really
appreciate them what I love about is a
lot of people have been cooped up in our
homes right and we've been we've been
you know not able to get out as much and
this is where you know now people are
finally leaving their homes again you
get a rad power bike it's just a lot of
fun whether you want a new way to
commute or to you know to get around the
city or you just want to get out nature
whatever the case is you've got to try
Rand power bites just give it a try and
you're gonna love it I guarantee it
it's a great alternative to public
transportation you know especially these
days and it's kind of a cross between a
traditional bike and a moped but it
doesn't require special drivers license
so there's no extra hoops you have to
jump through there's no red tape or
anything you can go 20 miles per hour
without pedaling so you can get out and
about without getting all sweaty that's
another you know you can get from point
A to point B and when you get there
you're not gonna be dripping with sweat
now other ebikes if you've looked at
them they're usually you know you're
gonna cost cost you three four thousand
dollars but these bikes start at $1,200
and all of them are under $1500 so it's
fun it's easy it's affordable it's
everything you could possibly want and
to show appreciation for those that
service rad power bikes is offering $100
off all ebike purchases for active
ex-military for first responders
teachers and students you get all of
that rad power bikes offers flexible
financing for as low as 0% APR right now
as a limited time offer to get a free
accessory with the purchase of a bike
that's right you get a free gift of up
to a hundred dollars in value and free
shipping to the lower 48 states to get
the special offer text the word bike to
64,000 that's bike to 64,000 text bike
to 64,000 now the president of
Minneapolis City Council was asked this
question on Sina about what what do you
do about crime if we don't have police
and here's what her response was we have
a state action against our police
department which gives us legal
mechanisms in the very short term you
know there's lessons from all over the
country all over the world that we're
looking to to take immediate steps while
we work toward building the systems that
we would need
to imagine that that future do you
understand that the word dismantle or
police free also makes some people
nervous for instance what if in the
middle of the night my home is broken
into who do I call yes I mean I hear
that loud and clear from a lot of my
neighbors and I know and myself too and
I know that that comes from a place of
privilege because for those of us for
whom the system is working I think we
need to step back and imagine what it
would feel like to already live in that
reality we're calling the police may
mean more harm as done so there you go
if somebody is breaking into your home
and you want to call the cops that's
just because of your privilege that's
the answer it's your privilege which
which by the way of course is not
actually an answer to the question but
that's that's how she feels so what
should you do someone breaks in your
home I guess lie prostrate on the ground
apologize for your whiteness invite the
home invader to take whatever he wants
or whoever he wants the TV the couch
your wallet your firstborn or whatever
you want so you go and tell you and
don't forget this I think it's this kind
of basic etiquette is that when the home
invader comes and of course you're gonna
you're gonna allow them to take whatever
they want but also offer offer to let
him kill you or you could also give the
option of killing yourself so because he
may not want to get blood on his clothes
you have to understand right because
he's gonna understand from his
perspective okay he's a home invader
he's coming to your home he wants to
take whatever he wants he's worried
about you being a witness okay so that's
a that's a real obstacle he's facing
right now and think about how worried he
is about that is it don't just think
about yourself stop stop stop being so
selfish that you're sitting there
feeling sorry for yourself someone's in
your home they're stealing everything
they're kidnapping your children and you
know what do you do it you're just
thinking about yourself the whole time
you see this is a problem this is
privilege this is your narcissism
talking so if you don't have privilege
and you want
and what you'll say is listen I know
you're worried about a witness you can
go ahead and kill me otherwise I can
jump out the window you know what
whatever you want you let me know and
we'll just do this how you want to do it
now so that's I guess that's her idea to
get a more specific answer to this
question of what we should do about
murderers and robbers and rapists if
there are no police departments I was
forced to go - tick-tock where all the
answers are given in the form of dance
unfortunately but this was the most
direct answer to this question that I
could find and it was on tick-tock and
here it is
[Music]
okay let's let's freeze it at the end
there with all the answers up on the
screen so you see all the answers are
this is brilliant stuff isn't it so who
do we call for ghosts we call the
Ghostbusters I think we're all on board
with that actually I'd prefer to call
the lady from poltergeist that's that's
my preference but no gross Buster's fine
of course the lady Ghostbusters we're
gonna call her and I could call them in
that's patriarchal now it says for
domestic violence rape and assault you
call social workers in trauma response
psychotherapists so these people will
come and they'll make you feel better
maybe prescribe some bills as far as
arresting the person who did this to you
you know the person who raped or
assaulted you well you're out of luck on
that that's where there's not gonna be
any justice look let's not go crazy here
he's just gonna go find the next victim
and those psycho therapists will be
close behind right on his heels giving
out drugs to all of his victims while he
just continues on and and that's gonna
be the system now for theft
it says social workers with defensive
armor will come and the CNN article that
I read by the way also said the same
thing they did briefly address this
question and it says that social workers
and victim rights advocates would take
the place of police so you call 911 you
know is like nine and one what's your
emergency
yeah I'm at the bank and there's a guy
here with the gun he's taking me hostage
well sir remain calm a victims rights
advocate will be there promptly with a
sternly worded letter everything will be
fine and if he happens to kill you don't
panic about that there will be a
psychotherapist they'll give
antidepressants to your family this
isn't even really funny actually because
this is this is like an absurd
outlandish parody of liberalism except
it's real life this is really what
they're proposing this idea of replacing
police officers with psycho therapists
and social workers in defensive armor
this is the kind of thing that you would
you would make up if you were creating a
satire of liberalism and then for
violent threats it says on call
community defenders will be
the replacements on call community
defenders you know we used to have a
word for people like that they're on
call you could call there's like a
special number you could call and their
job is to defend the community what do
we used to call those people over there
it's a police yeah that's what it was
now let's let's first second climb down
from the clouds okay climb down from
this fantasy world and talk about the
reality the actual reality what would
actually happen if you get rid of the
police if there are no police in a city
or anywhere else what happens well the
first thing is if you're rich good news
nothing happens to you rich people can
hire armed security they can hire
private detectives they can hire people
to perform the the role of police for
them privately and that's where many of
the fired and disbanded police officers
will go they're gonna go into private
security and they're gonna continue
doing the sort of thing they did before
except now they're doing it for hire by
rich people as for the non rich people
like you and me well we're gonna be at
the mercy of criminals and thugs and the
streets will be ruled by vigilante mobs
and armed militias and that's what's
gonna happen that's what has happened in
every country without reliable law
enforcement we don't need to speculate
about this just look at any failed state
look at any third world country and
that's what you find you find warlords
and mercenaries and vigilantes and armed
militias and this is a situation that
the left now seeks to create also keep
in mind that we're gonna move on from
this in a second but keep in mind the
the the the irony here of this and the
contradiction of it that it was just a
few weeks ago that we were talking about
the Ahmad R burry case and and we were
told that we you know we can't have
vigil we can't have armed vigilantes
going and chasing people down just call
the police you're not a police officer
you shouldn't be doing this and now the
same people who said that and I agreed
with them on that by the way that we
rather had police and armed vigilantes
now they're saying let's get rid of the
police
but what are we gonna do expect
coherence from these people expect them
to be consistent can't expect that when
you're dealing with people who are ruled
entirely by emotion this is what this is
what you get all right let's go to your
news headlines number one Mitt Romney
joined a black lives matter protest over
the weekend here he is black lives
matter he says and he's got the he's got
the selfie there that's what you do when
you really believe in a cause right when
you're there because you believe in it
you take a selfie and you put it on
Twitter that's what you do and this is
part of the the thing I've been talking
about over the last few weeks
Republicans endorsing black lives matter
black lives matter is an extremist group
it's a violent group he's a radical
leftist look at their website look at
what they proposed I read some of it
last week you know there's a lot more
there I mean of course they believe
America's inherently racist country they
believe that police are racist thugs out
murdering black people they believe that
white supremacy is this is this a deadly
threat that kills black people every
single day in this country none of that
is true of course they also believe in
if you look at the website they believe
in disrupting the nuclear family they
believe in trying to get rid of
heteronormative thinking whatever that
is these are radical leftist ideas and
you've got Mitt Romney out chanting
their slogan and marching with them
alright number two the good news is that
it looks like the NFL season will happen
the bad news is that we're gonna do the
whole kneeling thing again only this
time it'll be the kneeling thing on
steroids
you think you thought we had then we had
the whole thing with the kneeling the
last few years this is gonna be every
single game it's gonna be kneeling and
the Trump you know Trump is out tweeting
about it it's saying don't kneel and so
that's gonna encourage it even more so
we're finally getting sports back but
sports are just gonna be a platform for
the continuance of the culture war which
which it has been of course for a while
but now it's going to be that even worse
many players have announced their
intention to kneel ahead of time
including this the New York Post says
running back Adrian Peterson is going to
kneel now I thought this was fascinating
because Adrian Peterson you may remember
a few years ago he was a
arrested because he beat his
four-year-old son with a tree branch and
left cuts and bruises all over his body
his son was apparently afraid to talk to
police about it because he was afraid
that quote daddy Peterson as he calls
him will punch him in the face okay so
this is what this guy does to a
four-year-old child these on with cuts
and bruises all over his body beats him
with a branch and this guy is worried
about inequality and violence yeah sure
okay number three here's a picture I saw
online yesterday it's a picture of white
people out of protest washing the feet
of some black protestors I didn't want
to believe this was real so I looked it
up I found the video and yes my friends
this is this is very real watch this
Oh
[Music]
white rice and we just heard about one
racing
[Music]
allow me to just say as they're washing
the feet and they're announcing that
they're apologizing on behalf of the
white race on behalf of Caucasians as a
member of the white race as a Caucasian
myself
you are not apologizing on my behalf I
don't offer an apology I don't owe an
apology so you are not apologizing on my
behalf
those people whose feet you're washing
I've done nothing to them I owe them no
apology I don't give one and the feet
washing thing yes it is it is a common
practice among Christians it's a it's a
it's a significant symbol but Jesus
washed feet it as a sign of humility and
love that's not what this is especially
when you're doing it performative ly in
front of a crowd of a you know adoring
onlookers it's not about humility
actually it's the opposite of that and
doing it as an apology on behalf of one
race to another race that is not
biblical it's also not sane it's not
sane behavior number four and here this
this is from ubereats
they said as a new policy they said you
asked for a way to find black owned
restaurants on ubereats
we listened you can support an order
from black owned restaurants across the
US and Canada with a zero dollar
delivery fee so this is what they're
doing now we've got a little bit of
segregation so if you you can you can
search for restaurants according to the
race of the owner and avoid certain
races you don't well if you want to
avoid white people you don't want to you
don't want to patronize a white
establishment you can lubbers gonna help
you do that and then they're going to $0
delivery fee for
lack on restaurants what that actually
means is they have a delivery fee
essentially as a penalty for the
restaurants that are not owned by black
people and this is this is how we're
gonna bring about racial harmony right
is by segregation breaking things down
by race
financial penalties for certain races I
mean this is how you this is how you you
bring about a racially harmonious utopia
isn't it
finally let's get to our daily
cancellation now today I'm gonna be
canceling everyone who is trying to
cancel JK Rowling this is a rare
defensive reverse cancellation at DRC as
they call in the business now before I
execute this this DRC let me just say
that yes JK Rowling is a leftist she has
repeatedly over the years appeased and
coddled the very mob that is now trying
to cancel her so is this in some ways is
similar to the Jacob fry situation that
video that we play it's a very very
similar thing but with that said to
Rowling's credit she has recently been
taking a stand on an important issue and
she's been taking all the slings and
arrows that come from that I respect
that and anyway I will always defend
anyone who stands for common sense and
sanity whether it's JK Rowling or
anybody else even if you've even if
you've been on the side of insanity and
lunacy and irrationality for years if
you finally come over even slightly to
the side of common sense and sanity I
will all be right there with you
because we need all the help we can get
as far as I'm concerned so that brings
us to what JK Rowling said over the
weekend first I think this is what
started it she reacted to a headline
that included the phrase people who men
straight and she said people who men
straight I'm sure there used to be a
word for those people someone help me
out woman women woo Monde those all
sound like names from Harry Potter but
and that tweet got 30,000 responses
many of them extremely angry because
she's obviously in this tweet she's
insinuating that you know women men
straight and men do not and that is very
offensive stuff so rallying then
followed that with a series of tweets
and I won't read all of them but she
says if sex isn't real
there's no same-sex attraction if sex
isn't real the lived reality of women
globally is erased I know and love trans
people but erasing the concept of sex
removes the ability of many to
meaningfully discuss their lives it
isn't hate to speak the truth and this
of course set off a firestorm of
criticism much of it vicious and vulgar
as you might expect meanwhile what she
said is inarguably true I mean the only
part I didn't like is where she says
lived reality as I've said many times it
is pretentious and ridiculous to stick
the word lived in front of a word like
experience or reality because all you
can do with reality is live it if it's
if it is lived then it is reality if
you're living at its reality that aside
the stuff she says about sex is all
correct it's obvious it's common sense
totally uncontroversial for anyone who
isn't insane and who has an IQ exceeding
that of an oyster unfortunately there
are a lot of sub oyster IQs out there
and there are a lot of maniacs and
lunatics out there who don't want to
hear basic reality and in fact there's a
whole political party and a whole
ideology set up for these people and it
goes without saying obviously that none
of the people attacking JK Rowling could
offer any kind of counter-argument they
couldn't offer any actual like reason
why she's wrong about what she's saying
they couldn't do that instead they kick
and scream and demand that everyone
abandon reality for their sake and many
people are very happy to comply and this
brings us back to a point that I made at
the end of the show I think maybe on
Monday's last week sometime that you
know we we live in a world right now
where there are people not near they
want to get rid of the police department
we've got rampaging mobs in the street
and that's being endorsed by the left
the left saying men can have periods and
if you disagree with that you're a
hateful bigot and should be shunned from
polite society babies aren't people we
could kill 60 million of them and it's
something to celebrate
on and on and on this is why I believe
we are heading to some toy fracturing of
some kind I don't know what that's gonna
look like I don't know how it's gonna
manifest itself
I don't expect another bull run or
Antietam anytime soon but there will be
some kind of split there has to be
because you have one side of the
political divide that is so divorced
itself from reality has so rejected
common sense and truth and decency and
morality that there is just no way for
us to overcome that and ignore it and be
united this is what we've seen I don't
think there's any way around it the only
question is you know what does it look
like but the people who want to live in
a world with no law enforcement or
vigilante moms and and and you know it
rule the streets where we pretend that
that men can have periods where were
killed where we kill babies for the
crime of being conceived if you want to
live in a country like that then go have
your country I don't want to share it
with you and I think these differences
are far too deep and too real and too
significant and too fundamental to be
hashed out and argued over there is no
compromise there's no compromise between
men can have periods and they can't
there's no compromise between biological
reality and fantasy there's no
compromise between let's have no law
enforcement and let's let let's let
violent mobs burn down police precincts
and the other side of it there's no like
in between
it just isn't there's no compromise
between babies aren't people let's kill
them and babies are people let's protect
and love them there's no in-between and
that's the reality that we're currently
facing as I said where does it go from
here I don't know but it's not going to
a place of unity and harmony that's just
not going to happen I'm afraid to say
and we will leave it there on another
very positive note as always with this
show so I thank you all for listening
have a great day
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show every single
issue that has taken up by the left
quickly devolves into nonsense women are
men stop using fossil fuels and now
defund the police it's dangerous
gibberish and it's meant to be it's a
strategy and we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show